حسنًا ،
لقد جئنا هنا إلى هذا الذي يُقصد به أن
يكون متنزهًا ، لكنه في الواقع يمكنك
رؤية
منطقة كثيفة من الغابات خارج كييف
العاصمة الأوكرانية
حيث تم العثور على المنشق البيلاروسي
فيتالي
شيسوفا ميتًا معلقًا من شجرة
هنا
فقط  قبل ساعات قليلة من وصولنا إلى هنا ،
لقد وصلنا بالفعل
إلى مكان الحادث والشجرة الفعلية
حيث نفهم أن
الشرطة عثرت عليه في الساعات الأولى
من صباح الثلاثاء معلقًا من رقبته
هنا وإذا
لم أفعل  تعرف ما إذا كان بإمكانك رؤية هذا على
الكاميرا ، فمن المحتمل ألا تتمكن
الشرطة من نزع الحبل بعيدًا ، لكنه كان
معلقًا من هذا
الفرع فوق الأرض ، ربما
ربما 12 قدمًا فوق الأرض ،
أخبرتنا الشرطة أيضًا بوجودها
بعض الخطوات
مرتبة هنا خطوات مؤقتة باستخدام السجلات ،
كان هناك هاتف محمول خاص بـ
Vitali uh shishova أيضًا ،
لكن
السلطات التي تجري فحوصات الطب الشرعي تم استبعادها جميعًا
لمحاولة
الوصول إلى الجزء السفلي منه وهنا انظر
يمكنك  ترى أن بعض فرق الطب الشرعي
قد تركوا قفازاتهم المطاطية على
الأرض
هنا والتي استخدموها بوضوح لالتقاط
أي دليل
على قدرتهم على أن يكون بعض الأدلة الأكثر
أهمية من الجثة نفسها ومن
الواضح أن هناك تشريحًا للجثة يتم
إجراؤه في  في اللحظة ولكن وفقًا
لآخر تقرير للشرطة ،
هل تعرفون أه خدوش على الوجه
وعلى ركبتي حيوية كما في
كلام الشرطة أنه
سقط مرة واحدة على الأقل أحد زملائه
الذين رأوا الجثة من قبل
قال مأخوذ
إنه يبدو وكأنه حيوي كان لديه ندوب
موت عنيف ،
ومن الواضح أن هذا يغذي كل
الشكوك
التي تتسلل وتنتشر
حول هذا
الموت الغامض حسنًا ،
انظر جيدًا يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك كل
أجزاء القمامة متناثرة حول هذه
المنطقة بأكملها  من الواضح أنه حيث يوجد
نيران المعسكر ، إنه مكان تعرف أنه يستخدم
نوعًا ما
على الرغم من أنه معزول تمامًا
، من الواضح أنه يستخدم من قبل الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم  المشاة وأشياء من
هذا القبيل وهو المكان الذي
ذهبت فيه للركض عدة مرات في الأسبوع
عبر
مسارات الغابات هذه وبالطبع أنت تعلم أنك
ذهبت للركض مرة أخرى ولم
تعد السؤال عن من كان
أعتقد أنه مناسب لأنه كما قلت
كان Vitali
shachova داخل المجتمع البيلاروسي
هنا في أوكرانيا بارزًا نسبيًا ،
حيث كان يدير شيئًا يسمى منزل بيللا
الروسي
الذي ساعد الناس على الهروب من بيلاروسيا والهروب من
نظام ألكسندر ليجوشينكو ثم عندما
وصلوا إلى أوكرانيا ، تعلم
أنه وجدهم ساعدهم في العثور على عمل
سكنهم وأشياء من هذا القبيل ،
فقد نظم أيضًا احتجاجات وحملات
ضد النظام في مينسك
، ولذا كان عدوًا معروفًا
للسلطات
في بيلاروسيا ، وهذا كما أقول يمكن أن يكون
ذا
صلة بالغموض لماذا حدث
هذا ، وتقول السلطات إنها تحتجز
الحكم على ما تقوله الشرطة
في الوقت الحالي هو أنهم يبحثون في احتمالين
إما أن يكون هذا إما قتلًا أو كان
أو كان انتحارًا  أو ربما
جريمة قتل تبدو وكأنها انتحار
الآن كل شخص في مناصب عامة هنا المدعون
العامون والمسؤولون الحكوميون في أوكرانيا لم يصلوا إلى
حد
توجيه أصابع الاتهام مباشرة إلى
دولة بيلاروسيا البيلاروسية
ولكن هناك بالتأكيد نمط من
السلوك الاستبدادي بشكل متزايد أه استبدادي  من قبل الرئيس
البيلاروسي ألكسندر
لوكاشينكو قبل يومين فقط ،
حاولت بالطبع أن تخرج عداءة أولمبية روسية من اليابان
عائدة إلى بيلاروسيا ، وقد انتقدت
مدربيها في وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
وكانت منشقة بيلاروسية أخرى تحلق
على متن طائرة
فوق الأجواء البيلاروسية  عندما تم
إجبارها على الهبوط على الأرض في مينسك
وتم خلعه ولا يزال قيد
الاحتجاز الآن ،
فأنت تعلم أن الجميع يحتفظ بالحكم
في هذه المرحلة
حول من المسؤول عن هذه الوفاة ،
ولكن إذا تم العثور على أنها بيلا
روسيان الدولة البيلاروسية
،  من الواضح أن يمثل تصعيدًا كبيرًا
في حكم الفرد المطلق في ذلك البلد
فرصة cnn في الغابات
خارج كييف أوكرانيا